this is a festival going on in my
country of Mexico from the village of
San Juan de la Vega and it goes on every
Tuesday before Lent this explosive
festival combines Mexican men fireworks
and sledgehammers but the real star of
the show is former local boy David
guardiana who's pushing the firework to
sledgehammer a ratio to the scientific
max
so how does he create this epic
explosion without matches normally you
would use a lighter or a match that
would light a fuse they're not doing
that what they're using is a
touch-sensitive explosive as he smashes
the hammer down the whack causes the
chemicals to grind together now if you
imagine rubbing your hands together you
can feel them getting warm and this is
what happens with these chemicals and
this the heat source then sets off the
explosive part of the firework rather
than having to react with oxygen that's
in the air they've already got the
oxygen mixed in with all of the fuel and
this means that when they get the heat
source all the chemicals are already
mixed and ready to just go off taking
David with it okay but what's
responsible for David's airborne
excursion that was Newton's law for
every action there has to be a reaction
so do these gases blowing out and
instantly there's a reaction on the
hammer to throw it back
same way Rockets work if gas is going
out rocket goes up